WESLEY CHUN: Hey, developers,
this is Wesley Chun from Google
here to introduce
you to the newest
version of the Google Sheets
API launched at Google I/O 2016.
In this episode, we're
going to show you
how to use a new
v4 API by walking
through a simple
script that populates
rows from a relational
database into a Google Sheet.
Let's take a quick step
back before getting started.
We know that spreadsheets
have been a computing killer
app for decades, growing
beyond the business world.
And for nearly as long,
they have been programmable,
so it's no surprise it was
one of Google's first APIs.
Spreadsheets are a great
place for a structured data,
so it makes sense working
with them programmatically,
because data is
generally created
and may live outside
of a spreadsheet,
but can be easily viewed
and manipulated there.
While previous API
versions like v3
were good at creating new sheets
within existing spreadsheets,
writing new rows of data,
and, of course, reading data,
that's pretty much
all you could do.
Now that kind of
API seems incomplete
when you consider
that spreadsheets
are way more than that.
With that said, we're
excited to announce
we've launched a new version
that can do much more.
Think of what you can do from
a spreadsheet user's interface.
An API should allow your
code to do most of the stuff
that you can do with sheets
on mobile or the desktop.
That's the real power of v4--
the ability to do way more,
yet still keep things
simple for developers.
To get started with the
API, we need a SQL database
that has data.
Our codelab has the perfect
one, so click the link
and download the
zip file in step 2.
Extract the db.SQLite life
from the Start folder,
whose schema you see here,
and you're ready to go.
Now, you can do the
codelab when you're
ready for a deeper hands-on
using JavaScript and Node,
and it will help that you
already know its database.
Today, we're using Python.
Here's a preview of
the database rows
we're going to push into
the new Google sheet that
comes from that database.
To keep this a short
and sweet intro,
there won't be any
formatting this time.
We're just inserting
the raw data.
Before we can go
to the computer,
those new to using Google API
should catch our intro video
on setting up new projects.
While today's
script is in Python,
you can use any language
supported by Google API's
client libraries.
Be sure to watch the common
code walkthrough video,
because we're going straight
to the API code you see here.
Once you've got a project
with the sheets API enabled,
let's go to the computer
and see how to use it.
As we just said, most
everything through line 16
is part of the
boilerplate, except
for the necessary
imports we need
for this particular script.
And of course the
scope on line 10.
Because we're using
the sheets API,
we need to have the
necessary scopes here.
Also, make sure
you have the sheets
API enabled in the dev console.
Otherwise, none of
this is going to work.
All right, let's move
straight to the API code.
That's on line 18 through 22.
So on line 18 is where
we get the service
endpoint for Google Sheets,
so you can talk to the API.
And then we use the
spreadsheets.create function
to create the spreadsheet with
a bare minimum of information--
just a title with a time
stamp in the request body.
And what you get back is a
spreadsheet ID, which we save,
and then let the
user know on line 22
that it has been created.
Now let's turn our attention
to the actual database.
So in the next chunk of
code, lines 24 through 31,
we're not going to
touch the sheets API.
We're just going to grab
the data that we have
sitting in the SQLite database.
So you can see just a
bunch of field names.
We make the connection to
the database, grab a cursor,
execute our select
to grab all the rows,
and then insert the headers
in front of the rows,
so that's what insert 0 is.
And then the last step
is to basically assign
this to the JSON
payload that we're
going to pass through
the API, but we're
going to strip out the last two
columns, which are the created
date and the update date.
Now that we have the
data from the database
and we have a blank
spreadsheet, the next step
is to add all those
values to the spreadsheet.
And the way you do
that is by using
spreadsheets.values.update,
pass in the spreadsheet ID,
tell it what's the first
cell that the data is going
to go into, the data
in the request body,
and then this value
input option, which
we use as raw here.
There's another option
called User Entered.
User Entered is for the
situation where you're
going to pretend the user
actually sat at the keyboard
with a sheet in front of them
and are typing in the values.
The difference there
is that if the cells
have been pre-formatted
for numbers, or strings,
or have formulas,
then all those things
will take effect, versus
the raw data, which is just
throwing in the values
without any concern for what
kind of functionality
is already in the sheet.
So once that's done, we
have a print statement
to tell the user that the data
has been sent to the sheet.
And then just to
confirm, we're going
to call spreadsheets.values.get
and pull out
all the values that we wrote
in, and then we print that out
to the user.
All right, now let's go to the
command line and try it out.
But before we do that,
let's double check what
is in the database.
See the schema, you
can confirm that,
and then we can see
what rows we have.
All right, so we have five rows.
These are the same five rows
that should go into the sheet
when we run our Python
script, and that we're
going to dump out on the
command line because of print
statements.
So there's multiple
ways of confirming
that it read the right data.
Now let's run the script.
You can run this script
in Python 3 or Python 2,
it doesn't matter.
The code that we wrote
is compatible with both.
So the first thing
you should see
when you run the script
is OAuth, and what happens
is your browser
window will pop up
saying that this script
would like to have access
to view and manage your
spreadsheets in Google Drive,
which we want, so click Allow.
And then down below, you'll
see the output of the code,
because it runs pretty fast.
All right, so it created
the spreadsheet here,
and then wrote this data,
which we read in down here.
Now, that's great that we
can see the output of what's
supposed to be in our sheet.
But how do we really
know we have a sheet
and this isn't just
some fake demo?
Well, there's no better place
to check than your Google Drive
and see that you really did
create a new sheet right here.
So double-click it, and
look, it's the same data.
And if we close this
and our OAuth window
and run the same script
again, and boom, another one.
And if you click on that,
it's got the same data, too.
So one last thing.
You may be wondering why we
had to create a blank sheet,
read the data from the
database, and then call update
to throw the values in there,
and wondering if it's possible
whether or not we can do all
of that with just the call
to create.
And the answer is yes, but it's
a little bit more complicated
than that, because
when you use create,
you have to pass in
the JSON structure
for every single cell instead of
being able to provide basically
a list of lists
of just the data.
So the best practice is
to use the values update
method instead.
So congratulations, you just
wrote your very first script
using the Google Sheets API.
So that's it.
You now know how
to use the new API
to get data into and
out of a Google sheet
with not too many lines of code.
Look for an upcoming
episode where
we format sheets created
by today's script.
Check out the official docs
you see at the first link.
There, you'll find everything
you need to get started.
I'd also recommend
the samples page
to get a better idea of
the common operations
in the corresponding
JSON payloads you
need to send to the API.
Finally, the links
down at the bottom
will get you to more
developer videos
in this and other series.
The Google Sheets
engineering team
is proud to introduce
their next generation API.
Now it's your chance to
build new apps you weren't
able to do before, plus update
those existing apps to take
advantage of all
the new features.
Be sure to let us know how it
goes in the comments below.
And don't forget to
subscribe to our channel.
This is Wesley Chun
from Google, and we'll
see you the next time
on the Launchpad Online.